ça vous avez beaucoup parler de déclin
de spirale du déclin d'un manque de
grues vous avez aussi évoqué alain
chrétien
cette sensation de ne pas habiter dans
la même ville que vos concurrents sur
cette élection
j'ai envie de vous poser cette question
est-ce que vous assumez devant les
vésuliens en disant oui demain si je
suis réélu maire il faudra lutter contre
ce déclin il déclare il est relatif moi
quand je croise des gens dans vesoul biz
monsieur le maire qu'est ce qu'on a une
belle ville les gens de l'extérieur nous
dise quand on revient à vesoul
qu'est ce que c'est beau qu'est ce que
ça a évolué les bâtiments sont
construits des grumes j'ai compté
pendant le mandat à un moment donné on
avait six grues au centre ville le
palais de justice l'ancien hôpital
bref vesoul est en train de se
transformer et quand j'entends parler de
vesoul dans ces termes de déclin de
morosité
il faut il faut être positif et voir ce
qui se passe et la réalité elles
existent quand vous allez au centre
ville et que vous avez 300 habitants
supplémentaires qui habite maintenant
des logements neufs mais ses habitants
ils consomment au centre-ville
la dynamique elle est relancé je ne
comprends pas chez mille chez mes
collègues il ya un dénigrement de vesoul
qui ne porte préjudice à l'image de la
ville alors vous avez tous dit autour de
la table que vous aimiez vesoul qu'en
gros votre parti c'était vesoul votre
parti c'était la ville de vesoul
marie dominique aubry vous avez eu cette
expression en dix ans les 4 millions qui
manquent
les 4 millions d'économie je les trouve
dans quelques minutes est-ce que c'est
pas un peu démago de dire ça si je suis
élu maire je fais des économies de 4
millions d'euros
on m'a demandé un exemple je l'est de
nîmes il ya rien de démago dans ce que
je propose
moi je m'engage à faire des économies
moi je m'engage parce que je dois pas
habiter la même ville que le maire de
vesoul à l'heure actuelle le malaise des
divisions lien je les écoute et jolie en
temps et c'est à victor avec eux que
j'ai partagé toutes ces évidences
quand vous parcourez le centre ville de
vesoul ils vont surtout noter les
magasins vides depuis un an et demi donc
je pense qu'il faut répondre en avec
vérité et ne pas se mettre un foyer
devant les yeux en se disant c'est super
on en a plus il y à des glissements en
fait on vit de certaines parties le
palais de justice revient très bien mais
quid du bâtiment du palais de justice
actuel on vous dit les impôts vont
réintégrer une partie de l'inspection
académique
et quid du bâtiment des impôts place du
11e chasseurs donc un moment donné il
faut trouver des solutions pérennes et
des économies ni seront
ce cerf